you sing all the time i can't help it
but i do want to
i do want to say something to you i
brought you a gift oh because
there is only a few people that i can
re-gift
things too and the reason is
is because we share something we share
actually many things in common
but i would like for you to go ahead and
open this up now i got two
okay so i'm being honest with you are
these different necklaces
i think that's gonna happen anyway go
ahead and you'll see why i'm okay um
remember
oh my god okay so we have the same
initials
i know i was literally when i sent the
video memo today i was like from kc to
casey i thought it was so clever it's
not that funny
i got three of these sealer is
unbeatable
i love it wait is this for jewelry or
like what is it
what you do is you put them you put them
on your shoe and just so you know katy
kurt got the other one
oh there we go i actually know a lot of
people with our initials really it's
weird
what in the world is something like a
gremlin got out
it's a cocoa bar it's like a kookaburra
i can't say it
i can do it i actually practiced doing
him oh okay wait can you harmonize with
that do you think if we played it could
you harmonize with the kookaburra
okay robert yeah bendy can you bring the
bird out i'm gonna harmonize with
kristin
come on we're gonna harmonize we're
gonna do it
we can
all right okay he might not make a sound
now moe won't but hey can we play it
we're gonna try this is the sound this
is it okay
he doesn't know what to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
you are truly one of those people that
just
lights up the room like every room you
walk in and i i feel like we're
somewhere in the sense of like
we're both kind of like bubbly all the
time but are you always like that
no no i think it's and i think it's
important
to say this um i'm people think there's
a conception about me and probably you
too that it's rainbow
rainbows and unicorns and glitter all
the time but i'm human
and i've i've struggled with sadness and
even
i've suffered from depression depression
yeah and um
people are like really that that can't
be real but
it i do and i i have tools that help me
first of all i have counseling
i have a great mom that i talk to and i
have a great group of core girlfriends
that really listen
um and i think that's and i have faith
and and for whatever faith is for
everybody else
mine's god so that helps what else is
confused is it can happen from
sometimes left field and it can be a
small thing that kind of makes me go i'm
sad
and you pull yourself out of this you
put your big girl panties up
or you take the time and be sad and move
through it
i think you have to do that i think that
you know
also wanted to talk to you though
because i know you're dating
yes you're dating so like are you
getting married and do you want to tell
us now
okay um you know what i
i not to get weird but i think that also
it's important to say this especially to
our younger fans and younger generations
of women
i i come from the bible belt in oklahoma
very proudly so
but with that means that you're supposed
to get married have 2.5 kids and live in
the picket um
you know white picket fence house and i
didn't i didn't choose that for my life
i had other
goals and and at first it was always a
shame like i shouldn't tell people that
maybe i'm not sure about having children
or
even maybe getting married and i've had
great men in my life i've got a great
one right now
marriage might be the deal it might but
it's never what's been my
it hasn't been what's defined me or
driven me and for a long time i was
shameful about it
yeah especially from where we're from
because
and also thank you did people always
think you were gay people thought i was
gay forever
i've had some boyfriends to make me wish
i was gay but no
me too no i'm not and as far as like
people will go you're not gonna have a
child and it's almost like oh
selfish but i take care of a lot of kids
i have many cousins i have
god children i take care of and this is
also important to say
as an adopted child if i ever want to
if i have that so desire one day and i
wake up and i say maybe i
miss the boat or maybe i want to do that
there's been so many great examples of
women who've
done that um and i would i would just
adopt a child there's many things
the thing about the thing about that too
is
one that you're picked like my mom just
got stuck with me like
you were picked yeah that's like really
cool special feeling and i've always
known about my adoption and
you know my family they're all chemical
engineers and real tall and
you know they don't sing they don't sing
and they should never sing actually ever
but i don't do math but we learn from
each other you know that's awesome
that's so great all right well tell us
about your new album because i want it
well it's called for the girls i made a
record for the girls by the girls
all the women that have inspired me um
you know we're talking leslie gore
judy garland barbara streisand we're
talking eva cassidy
we're talking a lot of the greats and i
did it my way but i paid
i tipped my hat to the greats and on
because i'm a woman i asked jennifer
hudson and riva to sing it with me
and then i did i will always love you
with dolly which i can't believe gosh
that is insane
i my extensions fell out of my head
when she said yes and she's the
loveliest human ever that's the best
compliment ever has anyone ever met
anyone that doesn't like done the nicest
human
in the world uh the nice scent
and you also this is what i find
interesting you actually
you know you have a duet with ariana but
you've known her since she was little
right since she was seven years old
ariana grande she came
there we are we did hairspray live
together i love that child and she came
back to see wicked her grandma brought
her and she said
my my granddaughter wants to sing and i
said oh well that's sweet you know good
luck
and then she had superstars okay we'll
see
and then she kind of sang something and
i was like oh
i checked myself because she was really
good and i said here's a little wand
because i created the role of glinda and
i said
keep that with you and and have that
with you and she kept it all these years
we've stayed close
and i i wanted to bring i wanted to
bring her in the record and we did you
don't own me
leslie gore's tune and it's i'm so proud
of her yeah
oh my god that's so
it's cool super great so when are you
taking the album to broadway when can
people see it it's in november right
yeah the first two weekends in november
i'll be playing on broadway with for the
girls and have
very special guests come and it's at the
nederlander theater and you can get
tickets now and please come see
oh my god it's going to be great here's
the funny thing though we both have like
broadway in common and
yeah because we both well you're you
have like actual broadway
and then i just grew up in musical
theater but i love it
very different but my point is is i
remember my very first musical when i
was a little kid i was like
oh we're okay so we're just gonna break
out in song like
like we were just talking and then we're
just gonna break out songs
we call it monday i'm wrong i know but
it's so awkward it's a beautiful thing
but i was like how awkward is that that
you just like
go all of a sudden in song how can it
[Music]
she be my left talented
and long lost sister
oh my gosh so like the crazy thing
though yeah about this is now you're in
a movie
yeah and you're doing the hallmark thing
yes i love hallmark christmas there's a
good movie scott wolf's in it and his
dreamy blue eyes and i wrote the titles
on for it you'll love it oh my what's
the title song called
a christmas love story hallmark oh my
god that's so
great it all makes sense
[Music]
tell me about the tabernacle choir thing
that's crazy
can you sing with them the tabernacle
choir is a right of path you need to do
it
you're cooler than me let's just get
this that's going to happen i'll help
you so how did you get involved
they asked me to do it so i finally took
the opportunity and i got to do it
and it comes on in christmas oh i
finally found her
[Music]
yes
i
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going